now cigarette - prayer and welcome to a
little I'm pickling your balls you're on
hot balls Oh going get tub jeez this is
awkward
best introvert welcome ah I'm really
tired today and I don't know if you can
tell by this this but I said I was gonna
make a friend wrap every Friday and I
want to keep doing it because I want to
keep conversing with you bros even
though this is me talking but I know
you're there and I can see you at
sitting down watching this the first
thing that I wanted to mention is the
the charity the my charity water calm -
PewDiePie
ah you can check out that video if you
haven't and I wear the same shirt you
can just go there and be like whoa it's
a very cool cause we already raised
$220,000 Beezus
it's crazy beyond just making you both
happy the fact that I can use this power
over over this channel being so big -
something like that
it's so cool I'll do more for sure there
is ten days left to to donate in case
you haven't so if you haven't any tiny
bit helps I really do appreciate it bros
thank you all for participating so far
now to the thing that you all probably
been waiting for the challenge oh I'm
tired okay told you the the child
accommodation and all right breast
let's go through really really quickly
because I know half the people don't
give a [ __ ] about this first shout out
um wrecker really cool guy I actually
spoke to him a little Bay super nice he
has a nice channel but there are some
videos of me in here somewhere so that
should be fun
second one TJ Smith he sings like an
angel looks like an angel if I were gay
I would be okay third one intelligent
I why did I like about him oh yeah he
added a really sweet if he wants to add
in my video that'd be cool it looks like
he puts the extra effort and to have
this few subscribers to put so much
effort into a video it's just like ah
why poor guy so hopefully that will
change this guy plays a bass and he has
a Hayes space face I should not be a
rapper but this guy is definitely a bass
is it bigger bass I don't understand
he's cool okay top of the modeling
[ __ ] I don't even know this guy seems
crazy I really like whatever it is he's
doing he seemed really funny his name is
jacksepticeye you should check him out
as well uh Jo ashlynn makes like rock
guitar like a v8 like I it's pretty
pretty though all of our 20 it's 24 he
shows us how to draw really really good
yeah older it has a lot of subscribers I
mean if I were this good at drawing I
would be that making the same [ __ ]
channel prolly but I'm not messy
yourself he makes like look at that [ __ ]
that's titties I like that this is the
day life all dogs anyway I'm gonna get
in my car strike you funny and then we
have smile smile smile line Maron which
is really talented and I don't know if
you bros like or our channels are way he
does
you dropped obey but not me what that I
report this shout out alright so those
were the ones that drew my attention I
try to pick really different ones and
end people who stand out so yeah I hope
people aren't disappointed if you
weren't picked I'll try to make more of
these in the future that's all you may
think this is a giant blue dildo and
you're absolutely right this could be
nothing
what's the deal don't nailed it
[Music]
why this is not a Dell oh okay what why
that that doesn't mean
you guys perfect I'm not I just want to
say thank you both for being supportive
honestly since last time I spoke about
the comments there has been a huge
improvement and it's really fun for me
to read comments again and I'm really
happy about that
thank you was for doing that thank you
both for being an interactive viewer
instead of just being like ha ha ha ha
it's more cool when you bros getting
mauled that's that's more fun for me and
I meant I think it's more fun for you
bros as well without this video being
completely pointless and me just not
talking talking we're gonna finish with
a wall twerk so yeah I don't know how to
do it don't do this at home kids because
people might die out of sexiness can you
see my butt it's important that you see
my butt okay what do I do now well that
depends
how I suppose it's work like that wait
did I do it right can you see my butt
no you weren't looking at my crotch way
ahead thing how the hell are you twerk I
can't hate them you know you're [ __ ]
dumb when you can't even figure oh I
hope they put on my gravestone died
while attempting wolves work ah oh oh my
god can you see my ass oh I'm doing it I
look like a they need a woman
hey that's a proud moment alright so
yeah I did it say awesome rose thank you
for being supportive like I said I
really appreciate it
keep being awesome you keep getting
videos so deal I'm exhausted
hey alright hiccup Rob Fez and welcome
to I would just like to start off with
the apology I feel like I haven't done
these forever